[Music]
oh that's interesting no because this I
don't know you sound older like you look
younger but you sound older and I maybe
it's just because of what you do I hate
to go to the Embassy and do something
you know that's a scam but I I believe
them for one reason yeah wyt
wow me American
uh
they have you have some of the smartest
and the dumbest people in the world
[Music]
hi nice to meet you
I'm Melanie let me read okay
see you soon
you don't drink anything you like water
I need to be level-headed when I have
this kind of interview a real interview
I thought we were on a date well you
feel like it's an interview like a job
oh yeah it is too many too many men too
many men too many men too many men yeah
really you don't like it not really have
you ever speed dated
I mean it's not the speed dating that's
the problem they say never meet your
idol face to face in it your idol face
oh
wait wait wait wait wait where did that
go so so I'm a fan of you of you yeah
really
like what am I a fan of what's going on
when I do my stuff what stuff do you do
well I'm getting into my YouTube just
like yourself but at the moment I'm just
in the background doing my thing in the
background doing your thing yeah okay
I'm trying to help out and that but um
yeah I'm gonna get into the front soon
okay yeah we're getting to the front
soon what is what are you doing YouTube
or what are you looking to do what do
you want to do
um
same thing probably Paul does
same thing so like doing a podcast like
same type of content yeah you know it's
a tough space
yeah this conversation is boring oh wow
okay what you don't want to talk about
okay I want to talk about you changing
your hair my hair yeah what happened I
should change my hair change it back man
I should change it back to the
dreadlocks why you look cute oh I look
terrible now no you look terrible you
look cuter so my real hair makes me look
worse no
because this is my real hair and you
saying fake hair looks better most guys
tell me they would prefer me with my
real hair you got other real things
going for you
[Music]
okay like okay so you like that you like
that like the blonde dreadlock better um
what was it you liked about it so much
um I think it was more Effie
more earthy yeah suit your complexion
better than my natural hair yeah God
made me with this hair yeah you said God
made a mistake huh wait what did you say
I said God made me move a big head
so God made a mistake when he made my
hair he should I should be growing
blonde dreadlocks from my room no God
Gave You Free Will so you could change
your hair to how you want to change it
really yeah and I'm not saying
necessarily you're going to end up with
me so you could do your natural hair for
all you want but I'm just saying in
order to get me you'd have to go back to
that match reality wow really yeah there
you go back I have to wear a weave
get you you like girls with weave no you
you just said you do I don't like girls
I like women with wings no that's that's
that's women woman oh I have to so you
yeah like oh man you got me I don't like
women
you got me snorting which is a hard
thing to do I snort sorry when I laugh
it can be a little obnoxious
but it's me so we'll be going out
what are we going up aren't we going out
now no this is not good enough
private nice and romantic Garcon bring
us
so really my egging yeah and we're gonna
get you in a more settled where do you
want to go out
but wait you said you can't go out with
me because I don't have my braids in no
no I said your cuter with your brains in
damn you look amazing anyway but with
the with the braids that's just like
wifey material
every other guy I've met
that's why like in like
estan I actually like that look on me
yeah I personally
um I had to give it a break like I was
wearing them for so long like it starts
to get you know gotta let it breathe let
the scalp like touch the sunshine I like
how you change the subject you're
actually annoying me
because I'm trying to talk about like
you know wow
you're trying to wait till next she's
trying to wait till the next man come up
now
it's just you and I no it's not just me
I'm trying to do a date when it's just
me and you where we could just told me
about uglier I'm annoying yeah and
you're like where are we going haven't
you told me I'm annoying which woman is
not so you gotta choose the best out of
all of that and the best out of all of
that is right in front of me I just
don't like the color of the boots going
with the dress
I don't like about me I don't like the
fact that you don't take your YouTube
channel as seriously as you should
probably yeah you know what I've done on
YouTube
prior to the channel
I've been more successful than probably
everybody you know on YouTube right now
yeah but that's that's so I so I have
the privilege I have the privilege of
taking a break when I want to see that's
the that's your level though yeah but
but like where should I be doing what
should I be doing
that's a consultation fee and if we was
together it would be free but the price
is icy oh Lord God this is a trip okay
all right so
okay so I'm
not even ugly because no no you said I'm
ugly because I don't have wings you know
what I'm saying I'm annoying my boots
don't look terrible you don't have to
see you my boots look terrible
I'm not taking my channel seriously take
my boots off my mouth
tell me some more of what you don't like
this is so Charming
um it's every girl wants to hear about
the fact that you live in America
you are you know what I ain't even I'm
not missing I live in America god let's
go down
I live too far I need to take you to
Trinidad Trinidad are you Trinidad I'm
from Trinidad ah okay all right so wine
on your Carnival in them why don't me on
Carnival you gonna whine on a couple
girls in carnival yeah but why would I
do that if there's one come on now
Carnival is not about that one are you
supposed to hold it to the side and then
hold one woman and you know take a look
truly yeah okay what do you mean you
know what
yes
I'll give you a hug lad I'm not standing
up all right let me sit down okay okay
good club okay okay
you smell beautiful as well thank you
thank you that's the one compliment I
get I smell decent
[Laughter]
oh so you know who John B is
no but I don't want to know about John B
I'd rather nobody you know I mean I've
got this race I'm English English is not
a race it's a nationality you know that
right so I'm white I do find you
attractive how old are you
[Laughter]
um
thank you